360 حصريًا مع مقاتل سابق
لمجموعة Wagner الذي انشق كما
تعلم أن مجموعة Wagner هي قوة مرتزقة
يديرها evgeny pagosian
أوليغارشي روسي مقرب من فلاديمير بوتين.
في أوكرانيا ،
تم تجنيد فاجنر بكثافة من
السجون الروسية ، حيث حصل واغنر على الفضل في
المكاسب الأخيرة في المناطق المحيطة بباكمود ،
وكان هناك الكثير من التقارير عن
وفيات بين المدانين السيئ التدريب
والتجهيزات في فاجنر ، وتقارير تفيد بأن
أولئك الذين رفضوا القتال أو محاولة
الهروب يتم إعدامهم.  كتحذير
للآخرين ، تم تنفيذ أحد مقاتلي فاجنر الذي انشق
إلى القوات الأوكرانية ثم تم إرساله مرة
أخرى إلى روسيا كجزء من
تبادل الأسرى على الكاميرا
بمطرقة ثقيلة الآن رجل يدعى
أندريه ميدفيديف يدعي أنه انشق
عن مجموعة فاجنر.  عبر إلى
النرويج وتم إطلاق سراحه للتو بعد
إجراء مقابلة مع المسؤولين النرويجيين ،
إنه يأمل في الحصول على حق اللجوء هناك ،
قضى أندريه يتيم أربع سنوات في
السجن في روسيا بتهمة السرقة قبل
الانضمام إلى مجموعة فاغنر ويجب أن
نلاحظ أن خدمته في فاغنر قد تم تأكيدها
من قبل قائدها  pagosian الذي تحدثت إليه مع Andre
Medvedev قبل وقت البث
إذا كان بإمكانك التحدث قليلاً عما كان عليه الحال في
المعركة في ساحة المعركة مع
السجناء ، كيف كانوا كيف تم
استخدامهم ، ما هي التكتيكات؟
في حالة عدم تلقي أي خطط تكتيكية ،
حصلنا للتو على أمر للاستيلاء على
موقع العدو ، وكان علينا أن
نتوصل إلى خطة خطوة بخطوة
لكيفية تنفيذها ، كانت مشكلتنا هي
التأكد من تنفيذ الأمر
لك  لقد قلت في الماضي إنك رأيت جنود
فاجنر يُعدمون بسبب عصيان
الأوامر هو أن
مثل هذه الحالات الدقيقة تحدث في كثير من الأحيان وكان هناك
سؤال حول كيفية إقناع
المجندين الجدد الذين وصلوا إلى الخطوط الأمامية
ورأوا ما يجري هناك
وقرروا أنهم  لا تريد أن تقاتل حتى
تستمر وتقاتل ، فإنهم
سيجمعون أولئك الذين لا يريدون القتال
ويطلقون النار عليهم أمام الوافدين الجدد
لتطوير غريزة الحفاظ على الذات لديهم
لماذا قررت مغادرة مجموعة Wagner التي
أخطط لها  اترك فاغنر لفترة ولكن
لم تتح لي الفرصة كنت أخشى أن يتم
القبض علي وإطلاق النار عليّ كخائن ، أنا
مستعد للقيام بعمل جاد ولكني
أريد أيضًا أن أعيش في النهاية ، علمت أنهم
لن يتركوني أذهب  سأعود كجزء من
القتلى أو الجرحى ، فقد حان الوقت
لاتخاذ قرار جذري لولا
رفاقي ، لكانت قد
دفنت في بعض مناطق التدريب ،
كانت هناك
مزاعم وتقارير عن
إعدام مدنيين
ومدنيين  تم إطلاق النار عليّ أثناء سيرك في
الشارع لإساءة معاملة المدنيين ، هل
رأيت أيًا من ذلك ، هل شاهدت أيًا من
ذلك ، لا
أستطيع أن أقول إنني شاهدت ذلك لأنني
كُلفت بشكل أساسي بمناطق الغابات
ومناهج لباكموت ، لست على علم
بمثل هذه الحالات ، لا  بغض النظر عن ما لدينا من
قواعد سلوك صارمة للمقاتلين إذا تم
انتهاك هذه القواعد ، فستكون هناك
عقوبة على
هروبك إلى النرويج
والمكان الذي عبرت فيه
حيث قلت إنك عبرت
إلى النرويج ، فهي تخضع لحراسة مشددة للغاية على
الحدود الروسية
و  أثار بعض الأشخاص تساؤلات
حول كيفية قدرتك على الوصول إلى
الحدود نظرًا لوجود
الكثير من نقاط التفتيش في الطريق إلى
هناك بسبب كثرة
العبور في ذلك المكان حيث كان
يخضع لحراسة مشددة
وسأقول إن الحدود مع النرويج
حيث عبرت  ليست محمية بقدر حماية
الحدود مع فنلندا ، لكن في
هذه الحالة أنا ممتن جدًا بكل صراحة
للتدريب الذي تلقيته مع
وزارة الدفاع الروسية حيث قمت
بالخدمة العسكرية وأنا ممتن لفاغنر لأن
التدريب الذي تلقيته هناك كان
مفيدًا وأنا  استخدمها بكل سرور ،
هل حصلت على المساعدة في العبور لأنه
لا توجد العديد من نقاط التفتيش حتى
للاقتراب من الحدود ،
نعم لقد ساعدني عمال
مجموعات حقوق الإنسان في موسكو وأماكن أخرى
حتى المدنيين الذين سمعوا قصتي
عندما كنت أقترب  آخر مشاركة
بجوار الحدود ، ساعدني رجل
من فيرمونت وجد جواز سفر
لرجل يشبهني ، أنا
ممتن جدًا له ولكن لا يمكنني الكشف عن
هويته من أجل سلامته ، ساعدني جواز السفر
في تجاوز السيطرة  نشر
وتمكنت من الاقتراب من
الحدود
لماذا وافقت على التحدث لماذا
ما الرسالة التي تحاول أن
تفعلها تريد أن يعرفها الناس عن Wagner
عن تجربتك
كانت فكرتي هي إخبار الناس بما كان
يحدث هناك  وزملائي الذين ماتوا
هناك ماتوا بأوامر ،
لذا هدفي هو أن الأشخاص
المذنبين بهذه الجرائم يجب أن يقدموا
إلى العدالة وعندما تقول الأشخاص
المذنبين من تقصد وما
هم مذنبون
هو ذلك نعم  أنت تعلم أنني أود أن
أغتنم هذه الفرصة لأقول
علنًا أنه ربما يكون لدى قوم آخرين
وجهات نظر مختلفة حول هذا الأمر ، لكن الجاني الأول
هو بروغوزيان لأنه
القائد الأعلى بروغوزيان يدير مجموعة فاغنر
وهو المسؤول عنها ،
نعم هو مطلقًا والمنسق بأكمله
لفاغنر  يعرف الكثير والجميع
أنه يخضع
لأوامر الحكومة الروسية ، فالكثير
منهم يفعل ذلك بما في ذلك فلاديمير بوتين
جيدًا ، يعلم الجميع جيدًا أن ما
يحدث هناك هو قراره بالطبع ،
وأخيراً ، لقد خسرت أندريه كثيرًا
كما تقول رفاقك
في القتال.
ما الذي يجب أن تعرفه أمهاتهم ما الذي
يجب أن تعرفه عائلاتهم حول ما
حدث لهم ، لقد
كانوا أشخاصًا عظماء لأنهم
كانوا بشرًا حقيقيين ويمكنني أن
أؤكد لكم أن الكثيرين كانوا قضاة رصينين
لما كان يحدث هناك
كانوا مجرد أناس عاديين و  هذا
ينطبق على الجانب الآخر أيضًا
لأنني أتيحت لي الفرصة لرؤية
شجاعة القوات الأوكرانية أيضًا.
أندريه أقدر وقتك شكرًا لك ،
شكرًا لك